mr neider
so yeah let's switch to reading some
chat okay i'll open the twitch chat okay
for sure fortune either
i'm ready come on come after me
come and take oh bishop g5
f4 come on
it's probably a night or for oh well
queen e2 for real
so this is a night of lesson just for
free thank you so much
just just what i need
a free so
i wish i actually remember some theory
here
so maybe just bishop b7
i think h6
bishop b7 okay just g5 this is something
new to me
i always thought we should retreat to
the bishop or do something different
all right
h4 i mean why are you guys
everyone is sore let's say up up to date
with all the theory
everyone is so brilliant pierogi free is
clever so he's now protecting using the
third
rank but
but hopefully i'm still doing all right
here
uh jan is not having opening ideas to
reveal well
yeah everything i had
i have used before so he takes with the
bishop if i take the bishop like he
takes twice on b5
but i like queen b6 i think i can try to
take
the bishop because this gf6 would be
it would seem like a chicken move to me
but that's not our case
okay so he takes i take
so queen c5 and queen c4 even i can
calculate this but if queen b6
then probably rugby freeze the idea
also there is bishop b2 checking
intermediate move
so what are we playing for
for rules or not for moves
that's a big question wait can we
getting low so long time
okay we play for rating i have just
forgot this okay we are
all only play four is rating that's why
i playing for rating
so focus when i just focus and then i
just cancel
very solid extra piece brilliant
position
to bishops attacking everything you
should dream about in nigeria
everything all together here
so what's going on let's also see the
youtube chat
okay what's this i mean so brutal why do
why do why are you doing this to me why
do you win my
my own someone give me my phone back
please
what's going on amazing
just amazing okay all right
so i play like this
finally one of the games in this banter
when i actually lower on time
finally
okay are you attack i retreat that's
very simple
you attack i attack you retreat you
attack i retreat
that's uh that's what we can say about
the chess game okay now i attack and now
you retreat
get out roxy free
i can go what if i take
uh well
i can just take some material here
okay let's just take this phone i think
it's more variable when
than a hall rook now i feel brave
we are playing nader neither so we
should attack
especially when i'm playing against
someone with a nickname mr neidorf
we should we should just attack fiercely
as fierce as never before
we see four
and uh not even close
to the resigning so let's give couple of
checks maybe
we can grind out something
a couple more checks couple more checks
and all right
thank you for the game mr nider